نزل عشرات الآلاف من الإسرائيليين
إلى شوارع تل أبيب ليلة السبت
للاحتجاج على
الحكومة الإسرائيلية اليمينية الجديدة ، ولكن
بشكل خاص التغييرات المقترحة على
النظام القضائي ، يريد رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو وحكومته الائتلافية
تولي بعض
الخبراء القانونيين.  استدعاء أكثر
الإصلاحات جذرية للنظام القانوني الإسرائيلي في
التاريخ الإسرائيلي الآن التغييرات المقترحة
التي من شأنها أن تسمح بشكل أساسي
للبرلمان بتجاوز قرارات المحكمة العليا
بأغلبية بسيطة
وبالنسبة للمتظاهرين هنا الذين هم
عائلات شابة وكبيرة جلبوا كلابهم
يخشون على حياتهم.  المستقبل لسيادة
القانون من أجل حماية الأقليات
ويقولون أيضًا إنهم يعتقدون أن
هذه التغييرات ستمهد الطريق أمام
بنيامين نتنياهو للخروج في النهاية
من محاكمته بالفساد الآن
يقول بنيامين نتنياهو أن هذه التغييرات
لن تكون تدميرًا للديمقراطية  بل
بالأحرى تقوية الديمقراطية
بالقول أن هذه هي إرادة الناخب  الأعضاء
الذين صوتوا له هو وشركائه
في التحالف للوصول إلى السلطة في انتخابات نوفمبر ، ولكن
بالنسبة للمتظاهرين هنا الذين يقولون إنهم
ليس لديهم أغلبية في البرلمان
وأنهم لا يملكون دستورًا إسرائيليًا مكتوبًا ،
فإن طريقهم
الوحيد لمحاربة  هذه التغييرات هي
الخروج إلى الشوارع للخروج في
احتجاجات ضد ما يرونه كما
قال رئيس المحكمة العليا باعتباره
هجومًا جامحًا على النظام القانوني
هداس الذهب سي إن إن تل أبيب